hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to let's play that cares
less the amnesia custom story now this
is an absolutely incredibly highly
reviewed a custom story has a 9.6 with
over 50 reviews and that's almost
unheard of so here we go right into it
by team SD it's been two years now
Adeline my love it was a good idea to
take you back to their your home village
I know how you missed this place
it's so calm here I came with Eva your
little girl is five years old and she is
full of energy and joy I brought your
violin I just wanted to hear you play it
one more time I wish you were here I
will love you forever ha I probably said
that a bit too sinisterly I was supposed
to be with love and kindness but I have
no love in my heart
ok my name is Edwin Chester I am a
hunter this one should be the moor Ami's
I came to investigate an old castle
located in Hungary nowadays it's just a
hotel two of the disappearing stay put
the hotels to quarantine
while I was there as a customer they
didn't they didn't let me stay so here I
am outside I must break in
wait they didn't wait you were a
customer and you wait I will scatter my
diary pages all over the castle is a
warning in the case I don't make it wait
wait you're not the guy with the wife
right who are you
I hope no one wanders into the hotel
while I'm doing my job I hope I hope
what are you doing that could be your
job or you're just going Rambo all over
on the monsters they're probably so I'm
guessing that guy's either the villain
or someone else in the hotel at this
time I don't know don't seem like he'd
be the villain okay no back hat carrot
ass now this is a town that they were
going into black searched this tree it's
Hungarian so that's the translation yes
dear that voice sounded familiar that
book really did I swear I've heard that
from a custom story before um people
help me out here that didn't sound
familiar right I'm not losing my mind
that did sound familiar okay
poisonous no it wasn't poisonous
something else I mean it's not
tremendous voice acting but I can
overlook that if the game is incredible
cuz that's what's the most important to
me
I love amnesia and I love em Nisha
custom stories what's going on blackness
oh here we go
Oh kind of move oh no again I really
like the music the musical choices have
been very good so far I love a good game
that gives a good atmosphere to the
entire story it's really important to me
that because Oh looks like the daughter
has gone missing of course she wandered
off on her own
ah where I'm not the voice actor here
okay there's a note here I think it's
been two years now oh wait I read that
already here we go can I go back into
the village
oh my daughter's gone oh well that's so
sad now I've lost my wife and my
daughter
oh look a castle it seems pretty
familiar standard fare for amnesia I
know a child could fit through that
whole strange observation to make but
okay oh hello whoo
this is Eva's toy I wrote another note
I'm doing a lot of right okay I have to
find Eva don't did you solve for me
let's check the front door that's
actually really cool there's a custom
item here that is a freaky looking bear
yeah that's a really strange looking
bear but kind of cool because that says
that there's custom items and custom
stuff which I am very much looking
forward to why doesn't that front of the
hotel point towards like civilization or
something need to find a proper tool to
tear down those boards and fast don't
tell me what to do I can't move this
never mind
ah-ha-ha crowbar Sidorov mere does
everything seem a little bit bigger
that's what she said okay Jake oh there
was a note on the door let me read it
first due to the recent disappearing of
hotel customers the mayor of the town
has commanded that the hotel be closed
until the disappeared Hotel guards have
been found town guards quite impersonal
don't you think
oh I don't even need to click on
anything I'm just going around I have to
find IVA she is all I have ah you son of
a [ __ ] anything under here well this
looks nice for a dankey de Bandhan hotel
anything no I doubt that they just store
all their valuables right here without I
don't have a lantern okay oh it actually
has a receptionist thingy cool breakfast
will be served at blah blah do not enter
the storage due to recent water damage
[Music]
amnesia more than meets the eye okay so
we got a little bit of mystery going on
there's a so hello whoa
library Keys cellar key well this is
awfully convenient
okay empty empty Stephano ha ha ha
Gordon Freeman Bruce Wayne wow this is a
really Rick no badge 14:08 wasn't that a
movie wait a minute riggan reins I don't
know who that is
Edwin Chester Bruce Wayne ha ha
ok so let's carry on let's not go in
there just yet let's explore a bit
there's a lot of place to see here
plenty of stuff and I'm bored already
let's get to it
what's in here stow don't go in the
storage there's water damage I'm going
right in the storage first thing this
castle is supposed to be abandoned I bet
it's not just saying I bet it's not oh
look
water damage no that means all the food
would be spoiled I still need a lantern
but thankfully it's just bright enough
for me to see an ominous glowing blue
light permeates the burning darkness on
I don't see anything else to value no
loud down and what's it why would you
need multiple of those there's a lot of
stuff in here I'll tell you that seems
like a prime location for a water
monster of sorts see half it screw you
there we go hi hi okay
aha what is this parlor key ah ah [ __ ]
you give me up out there what what what
no no yes No what was that was he really
there was that just a joke that was just
a joke wasn't it I got the Barlet key
I'm getting out of here ha ha I don't
know what that was all about wait I'm
not sticking around to find out I just
like the water monster very much so very
much so I must find a source of light
somewhere indeed I must ah the nice
music what's over here something else
sinister are the parlor well good thing
I got this maybe I can find a source of
light in the parlor I'm either I'm
either guessing like absolutely
correctly or I'm way off base wow this
doesn't even kinda look like amnesia
this looks like a lot of custom stuff
has been going on here no thank you I
don't want any your horrific demonic
presence is not appreciated here
[Music]
hello I dunno what's going on
I'm dog waiting out oh that's new oh
Jesus
what is this doom holy crap oh god that
is like the coolest did creepiest thing
I've ever said about that give me higher
I wanna go home I wanna not be in here
got a sledgehammer
Babu ski oh boy let me out let me out
let me out
teddy bear teddy bear Tommy Turner I can
use it on something why can i I don't
have a light if there's something else
hidden here I can't see it
I just hear the wailing calls of the
Damned how do I get out of here that is
not a pretty sight
okay so just think logically how would I
get myself out of such a precarious
situation
let me out sledgehammer the door hush Oh
let me out
oh god when all those fails throw
something at it what key did I get I'm
getting a lot of keys
if something happens to Eva I can't
forget myself well why did she go in
this place to begin with why
sounds like dumb-dumb this on her part
very stupid stupidness I'm impressed by
the load times oh because look like this
is a lot of detail in this game and
they've been loading like really quick
okay library let me not go there what
did I just got the servants from I
definitely need to find a lamp lantern
what do we got what do we got what do we
got come on now
no thank you I don't want any Jesus I
really like the atmosphere of it I mean
seriously the atmosphere is like amazing
I'll go to the servants Aryan next so
I'll hit the library first I'm assuming
that if I need to get something from
somewhere else it's gonna tell me
because so far I haven't been given that
many clues as to my purpose
well to find Eva obviously but oh this
looks this would look nice but instead
it does not
it looks very unknown
no come on are they my anti-monster
device ah screw you I don't care
Heidi place let me just clear this out
for when I'll need it in the immediate
future nope do what's back here
something behind the stairs some finally
behind the stairs nothing nothing's ever
behind the freaking stairs what's in
here hello
aha here we go another key Thank You
East Wing
what okay
[Music]
look nothing enough of that
silliness the monsters will do it plenty
of that no need for me to contribute
okay so I found it I found a key of some
sorts I don't see anything else and it
would take me forever to pore through
all these shelves try to look for
whatever I need but I think I know oh no
you did it Oh screw you go away go away
I'm guessing it was just standing there
oh no this is how I got to get out there
[Music]
no thank you
don't want any please no this is the
statue so kind of channeling me through
[Music]
oh where is it something out there so
bad out there but don't know what is
happening in this place oh no no no I'm
did the guest oh hey so nice oh man okay
so I am actually all out of time for the
first part this looks like it's gonna be
an absolutely tremendously awesome
amnesia custom story so I hope you're
all excited about the future so thank
you all so much for watching click the
annotation for more videos it I've done
and as always I will see you in the next
video
[Music]